el futuro político de Boris johnsonpende
de un hilo este miércoles el comité
parlamentario de la cámara de los
comunes lo interrogó por las
declaraciones posiblemente falsas que
hizo al parlamento cuando fue
interrogado sobre las fiestas de downing
Street el año pasado si la comisión
concluye que mintió deliberadamente
podría ser suspendido o incluso perder
su escaño en el parlamento
estoy aquí para decirles con la mano en
el corazón que no mentí a la cámara
Cuando hice esas declaraciones las hice
de buena fe y basándome en lo que
Honestamente sabía y creía en ese
momento cuando se abrió esta
investigación confiaba plenamente en que
no encontraría nada que demostrara que
yo sabía o creía otra cosa y de hecho no
lo han hecho Johnson aseguró
repetidamente a los legisladores que él
y su personal siempre habían seguido las
normas en downing streets
Gracias señor presidente puede el Primer
Ministro decir a la cámara si hubo
fiesta en downer instruir el 13 de
noviembre
no Pero estoy seguro de que pasará lo
que pasará se siguieron las directrices
y se respetaron las normas en todo
momento
incluso cuando el informe de sucre
provoca una serie de fiestas con gran
consumo de alcohol tuvieron lugar en
edificios del gobierno durante el
confinamiento Johnson argumento que no
tenía conocimiento de Tales eventos Y
que cuando asistió a algunos fueron
reuniones de trabajo legales sin embargo
un deporte publicado este mes sugiere
que habría sido obvio para Johnson que
tales fiestas tenían lugar Boris Johnson
Julio pasado en medio del escándalo del
partigate y de varios otros escándalos
de uso de recursos públicos